On a mis des tee-shirts
C'est un peu ridicule en fait on
les a cramés avec le fer à repasser
On a essayé de les faires nous mêmes
et on les a cramé au fer à repasser
et en plus on dirait des polos de deux
vendeurs de voitures garage de voitures
Bonjour je suis Olivier de carglass
Normalement on sort cette vidéo en partie 2.
On ne va pas spoil ce qu'il
y avait dans la partie 1.
C'est bon il vient !
Qu'est ce que c'est que ça ?
Je ne connais pas ce sytème
Ce ne serait pas le haut d'un barbecue ?
Attention ! Je vais tirer
Pourquoi il est dans la cagette ton chien ?
Il veut partir à la ferraille,
Il a dit : Je serait mieux chez le ferrailleur
Je crois que c'est un bout de bois
C'est un poteau
Il a un problème ce chien
J'ai quelque chose
Je prends les paris !
Ca n'a pas l'air d'être
aussi lourd qu'un vélo.
Une trottinette ?
Moi je pari sur un autre bout de ça
Un siège de voiture ? De bateau
De bateau ???
Est-ce vraiment un siège ?
Alors là mais beaucoup de plastique alors
Rasta, tu es l'expert aujourd'hui
Dis nous ce qu'il en ait.
Bizarre, bizarre
J'espère que c'est un peu mieux que les
deux précédents
Même si ça sera sûrement dans la même lignée, on va
voir ça tout de suite. Découverte en direct
C'est l'autre partie. C'est un capot de barbecue celui-là
C'est quand même une premièreun barbecue aussi gros
Ouais, c'est pas mal en vrai !
C'est pas sûr qu'il indique
encore la bonne température
Ca se tient, le minimum
Belle pêche !
C'est devenu un niveau à bulle bon eh bien
J'espère que c'est un autre pied du barbecue parce
que là en fait il nous manque trois pieds
Pour réussir à reconstituer un barbecue
Si on a les trois on va essayer de le faire
Par contre, il ne sera plus à gas. Oui oui bah oui
Ce sont les pieds
C'est bien ce que l'on pensait
Il y a peut être la bouteille de gaz
Ah non
Pour le remonter, ça va être compliqué du coup ça va il faudrait
souder un peu
Regarde en fait, on a tout.
Il ne manque que la bouteille
Super !
On a un problème avec Rasta
Si vous savez ce qu'il faut faire dans ces
cas là
Il fait une tête de chien battu dans la cagette
J'ai l'impression qu'il en a un peu
marre de la pêche et qu'il veut rentrer
Un tiroir !
Regarde ! Oui c'est encore un morceau du barbecue
Super
Cette fois est-ce qu'il en reste ?
Il en a reçu dans la tête. Oh non Rasta !
Il faudra le doucher le petit
J'ai quelque chose ! Toi aussi ? C'est rempli
Regarde, regarde !
Encore du barbecue
Un deuxième ???
On avait déjà fait un couvercle ?
Ah oui !
La vraie question c'est
comment passait les péniches
Non, la vraie question c'est : Y a-t-il un gang de voleurs de barbecue ?
J'en ai un autre !
Alors, barbecue ou vélo
Du coup barbecue haha ça n'a aucun sens
Justement il me fallait un barbecue
Oui oui, encore un barbecue
Le même tiroir, ils se ressemblent
Le gang des voleurs de barbecue
J'ai quelque chose encore
Un lancé égal une sortie
Un lancé égal un barbecue
Des pieds pour le deuxième barbecue
Image on sort 15 barbecue
On pourra ouvrir notre entreprise de vente de barbecue
Ca nous change de pêcher des armes
Il mange les algues
Non non !
Laisse le il est petit
Il est petit mais il mange n'importe quoi
C'est pas lourd
Un panneau ?
Un panneau , un peu d'originalité
Regardez la belle trouvaille
NON !
Encore un trépied !
Baptiste déteste car je m'en sert comme d'un trépied de caméra
En plus il manqueun pied donc c'est encore plus chiant
Du coup c'est mon deuxième, mais dommage, j'aimerai bien trouver le pied qui manque
Petit trépied de pêcheur
Bon tu nous pêche quoi ? Des barbecues encore ?
Je t'ai dis, tant qu'on n'a pas fait les deuxbarbecues complets on ne bouge pas.
Mais regarde le chien, il n'en peut plus
C'est toi qui n'en peut plus !
Moi je suis très bien, assis en train de te filmer
C'est sale !
Du cuivre !
C'est bon ça !
C'est le début de la richesse
Si c'est une grosse bobine de cuivre, je ne dis pas non
Je vais enlever mon sac, c'est ridicule.
Oui
Il me semble que j'ai un bout
C'est superbe une éponge et ça c'était à manger
Tu crois que c'étaitcarrément de la nourriture ?
Il reste du pâté dedans
Non c'est peut être de la graisse pour nettoyer
En tout cas, c'est l'éponge pour récurer
On a tout ce qu'il faut pour le barbecue
Attention , si lui il voit la bouffe
Peut être qu'il y a les merguez au fond
Vous pensez qu'on peut pêcher les
merguez avec des aimants ?
Je pense  que ça se tente, on a déjà fait bien pire
Il y a du poid
C'est bon, il n'est plus dans la vase
On voit les pieds ! Il est à l'envers
Un barbecue !
Il est entier !
L'aimant a laché
Bon , on laisse comme ça ?
Oui c'est bon on a fait notre travail
On ne va pas non plus le sortir de l'eau ...
Ca fait une petite plateforme pour les pêcheurs
Saute dessus vas-y!
Mais non je vais le casser ...
Non non ne le casse pas
Je vais l'attraper par l'intérieur
Allez on va le chopper!
Regardez les précision.
Rasta l'a repéré
Oups
Ca fait quand même le boulot
Il est accroché dans le pied
Ouais ouais c'est pas malau final
Il est entier je crois ! Il ne manque le couvercle
Camping gas, je pense que se sont ceux qu'ils laissent sur les bateauxde location
Design in France
Il a dû passer quelquesmois dans l'eau
Commentez si vous avez le même barbecue
Oh merde
Tu as cassé le bouton !
Non il n'est pas cassé. - Ouf
Bon et bien voilà, la vidéo toucher à sa fin
Donc ces barbecue, c'est très louche
Mais on nous a dit que c'est parce que lespéniches passent sous le pont et elle tapent
Donc les barbecues tombent
Mais on n'écarte quandmême pas l'hypothèse d'un gang de jeteur de barbecue.
Donc à suivre !
On va à la maison ???
Voilà, donc en pleine restauration du barbecue
Pêché à l'aimant !
Il sera un petit peu rayé
Regarde il commence à bien ressortir
Bien rayé oui !
On s'en fou pour faire des grillades ! C'est pas trop gênant
Voilàon a allumé le petit barbecue à gaz
Convertie bien sûr en barbecue àbois
N'ajoutes pas trop de bois, tu vas mettre le feu !
Pour une fois c'est une pêche qui sert tout de suite !
La restauration a été plutôt rapide !
Donc là on faire de bonne grillades et commencer l'apéro
A la semaine prochaine pour une nouvellevidéos de pêche à l'aimant.
Avec je l'espèrecette fois ci, une plancha ou une friteuse